NARRATOR: Luxor, Egypt.
Here lies the tomb of
the world's most famous
pharaoh, King Tutankhamun.
When it was discovered in
1922, completely intact
and preserved after
more than 3,000 years,
it was considered
one of the most
significant archeological
discoveries of all time.
But as spectacular
a find as it was,
almost a century
later, new evidence
has come to light
that there may be
much more to King Tut's
final resting place
than meets the eye.
While examining high
resolution scans of the tomb,
on September 28 of 2015, British
egyptologist Nicholas Reeves
found something remarkable--
the possibility of
two hidden passages
connected directly to
King Tut's burial chamber.
There was a
Spanish company who
was recruited to scan
the tomb of Tutankhamun
in order to replicate it.
It is through this high
definition photography scanning
that Reeves noticed that, on
the north wall of the burial
chamber, there are
some cracks indicating
the possibility of a door,
and also on the eastern wall.
So there's two
possible chambers.
RAMY ROMANY: Reeves
took his laser images
to Dr. Mamdouh Eldamaty,
who is the Minister
of Antiquities in Egypt.
And they both decided
to dig further.
They used thermal
scanning, which
tells you the exact density
of the wall at every part.
And they have confirmed that
they might have discovered
another passway, or
a chamber behind King
Tut's burial chamber.
NARRATOR: Whether
there are more buried
treasures beyond the painted
walls remains to be seen.
But if so, Reeves has a theory.
He believes the passageway
may lead to the tomb of Queen
Nefertiti, the wife of
Pharaoh Akhenaten, who ruled
during the 14th century, BC.
ROBERT BAUVAL: Reeves speculates
that, in fact, Tutankhamun
inherited the tomb of Nefertiti.
The reason is this.
The tomb of Tutankhamun
is very unusual.
It's rather small compared
to the other pharaohs.
All great kings of
the 18th dynasty
have amazingly large tombs
with store rooms and chambers
and so forth.
Tutankhamun's tomb, if it
is his tomb, is very modest.
NARRATOR: But why
would Nefertiti's tomb
be hidden beyond King Tut's?
Ancient astronaut
theorists believe there
may be a profound reason--
that Queen Nefertiti
was not of this world.
Nefertiti's
parents are unknown.
On pictures, she's shown with
one of these elongated heads.
Now, we know the gods--
the old Egyptian gods--
they had longer
heads than we have.
And according to
the pyramid texts,
sometimes, they left Earth,
and then they returned again.
So Nefertiti's parents were
maybe extraterrestrials.
King Akhenaten
and his wife looked
completely different than
all the other ancient
Egyptian kings.
King Akhenaten
always was depicted
with an elongated skull, a
bigger-sized hip, a belly that
draws over his belt. He
believed that he wasn't a man,
and he wasn't a woman,
and he wasn't a king.
He was just something else.
ROBERT BAUVAL: The
most unusual feature
is the elongated skulls.
There's been a
lot of discussions
about what these skulls meant,
whether they were literally
elongated skulls or whether they
were just decoration features.
It's certainly very intriguing.
It doesn't appear
before or afterwards.
So there's something rather odd
about this, I have to admit.
NARRATOR: The reign of
Akhenaten and Nefertiti
introduced a new
and controversial
monotheistic faith to Egypt--
worshipping the
disk-shaped sun god, Aten.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS:
The Aten was described
as this flying sun disk.
Egyptologists are
merely saying that this
was nothing else but the sun.
But the question is,
can the sun instruct
you in different disciplines?
And the answer is no.
So we have to see whether
or not our ancestors
encountered technology
and misinterpreted
it as something in nature.